the Joe Rogan experience occasionally
they would go [ __ ] you and they'd kill
the guy and then a new guy would rise
that's what we should be doing we should
do all that [ __ ] now do that did you see
the video of Trump talking about taxes
do what he says I can check it out one
guy sayers yeah I'm gonna charge you 25%
it's I sent it out yes [ __ ] amazing
that that's the price there's two parts
of me man there's one part of me that
loves this oh do I love one part of me
that's good ha it's great material
there's so many fakes and phonies and
ridiculous career politicians that have
to watch this guy say listen
[ __ ] you're gonna pay 25
percent taxes and everybody goes crazy
and players yeah because I like they
can't believe he's really saying it but
it's stuff they would say too if they
didn't have any reservations well it's
maybe but let's play it because it's
hilarious I'm telling you man I'm not in
favor of the wall I'm Pro immigration
I'm not a favor these ice busts and all
that jazz but [ __ ] like that one's me
over I said the guy is the [ __ ]
President and he said listen you
[ __ ] is he gonna pay 25 percent
taxes he says it years before the
campaign he doesn't say how many years
20 but what you know what's funny I was
talking about on stage I'm so tired of
being yelled at by like online about
people hate him like listen I'm not a
huge fan of them either but so many
people are like I hate him I hate him I
hate him that now I kind of like him
like you know how enough people say [ __ ]
you're like [ __ ] you I'm so tired of you
telling me your opinion it's all the
same to also what annoys me is when
someone goes
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's like that's it
that's all that's what you did
you you you you put like that's not
doing anything by going hey Trump suck
my dick all right dude well you got him
here's my take on that if it's that if
it's [ __ ] more and you're not even
supposed to listen that's supposed to
not even go in I know because it's not
if this is not effective communication
so if you engage that guy don't I just
completely waste your time even if you
get upset it you're completely wasting
your time I wipe it away I bet I see it
now I'm like oh come on this the works
the one that gets me is Nazi [ __ ]
Nazi Nazi oh yeah he's a Nazi and you're
a Nazi fascist they throw these words
around they really don't even know what
the [ __ ] they're saying like if you
really think that everybody looks likes
Trump is a Nazi you're missing that's
insane
you're missing a giant point you're
[ __ ] up everything you're ruining
this conversation right you're right
about a lot of the [ __ ] he does wrong
but as soon as you say he's a Nazi
right and that there's not see
everyone's a Nazi well then when real
Nazis come around you're gonna better
have a better name new yeah yeah you
can't the cool Nazis do you can't
[ __ ] take the word Nazi and apply it
to [ __ ] that's not Nazis that's
dangerous like they say the Pacific word
like cost him on a murderer why'd you
call him a murderer cuz he yelled an
insult at that man okay that's not a
murderer
right but you can't do that the same
thing with calling someone a Nazi that's
not an onsen he might be a [ __ ]
he might be a fool he might be into
Trump just because he's a dumb guy and
he likes the fact there's a white guy in
office but that doesn't mean he's a Nazi
it's also like the biggest problem that
I have is like you're it's still illegal
to be an [ __ ] it's not illegal to be
a dick right if someone someone says
something you don't like where it's not
against the law right so like this idea
of you tagging someone like they're the
biggest criminal in the world cuz they
said something you don't like that's
crazy to me like people are allowed to
not [ __ ] think what you think is right
right Brian they're trying to redefine
what's acceptable by calling words
violence like they're calling saying
things as hate speech is real right I
don't know though see it's funny that's
real if you say something like [ __ ] the
Jews I hate all Jews Jews should die
that's hate speech okay it's to me it's
this if you said if a guy said [ __ ] the
Jews I disagree with what he says you
should say how do you welcome you're
welcome Jenny asked if I confront the
balance [ __ ] come on dude go go around
the world what do you think of that
chapter
I think it's like what listen that
person that person what hate speech to
me is like it's just a big huge term
that can encompass so many things I
don't really know what it is right
does it incite violence if I said [ __ ]
the Jews does that incite violence
it shouldn't no that's just that if I
said [ __ ] your shirt it only inside
didn't incite you to tear a shirt I was
pretty close as soon as you the way you
said shirt I was like yeah letting a
shirt revolution yeah [ __ ] your [ __ ]
shirt [ __ ] shirt bro seriously bro
you sure way [ __ ] the Jews works is if
someone also thinks [ __ ] the Jews and
then you like find like-minded [ __ ]
but that's gonna happen no matter what
but it's not gonna happen if you don't
say it then so the idea is like can you
suppress it
[Applause]